yes what is Chihuahua vehicle so this
order yes over the border from El Paso
Texas welcome er here first key bro it's
a problem Sahara Mexico like being in
the Mafia and doing all these killing
but yeah all the violence and me in it
too when I was in there well huh when I
was in Mexico either you had to be a
part of it or they will kill your family
yeah there are and there from there so
you change I moved to Texas and I still
had to go because there were like it's
just over the border so yes yes
connected kill killed up keepo in funny
in front of them to see if you really
have the balls you really have the boss
to do it yeah you have to tell somebody
either if you don't do it either they go
for your family or cuz you are ready in
there they tell you to do something and
if you don't do it they fall for your
family oh I kill anybody that put in
front of me just anybody grab yeah not
before ever used to be killing the girls
you know way back years ago they used to
playing girls with no head or you know
shop chopped up into bridge Raiders and
bags yeah we have to do other
I do like shakes not with a knife yeah
you just shove it up no I'm not sure it
didn't put me not Sheldon just woman or
men and people I don't know well at
first it was a thrill it was a thrill I
had a thrill a good feeling but then
yeah but then now I think about it and
it's like kind of weird kind of that's a
feeling where that I can't believe I did
that in order for me to be in the Mafia
I'm not in effecting a life yeah yes he
does he does it affects you bad
mentally yeah thanks you yeah that's why
I drink sleeping pills to just let me
out because everything goes back to you
comes back and you can't sleep I mean
you're you gotta be watching like your
back
in the end your giving you an ultimatum
of either
do this uh-huh yeah all your family yeah
yeah that's true
and it's it's a rough life you know so
you you skate I'm not I asked cave I
went to a Kim over here no it wasn't far
enough because it's just the border
though yeah I think you still get you
know at first it was so easy to pass by
to pass over the water so and then they
got people on the other side too looking
for you I mean if they put the green
light on you that means that you're gone
this was like twenty years thirty years
ago twenty thirty years ago that's when
I was still young
now I'm 55 and now I think more better I
mean not more better because I'm still
doing drugs and it's not a good feeling
we're just gonna tell you it's real it's
real other it's really what is this
getting better but still the gangs they
you don't end up they're still there
violence a lot of violence up there
that's why sometimes I'm kind of scared
lower back cuz they already put the
Google ID on
yeah I'm gone
yes I got seven in there
exam yes I got five children for living
one passed away in a car accident and my
youngest one is 16 years old grandma my
mom yeah she's she's racing huh well cuz
they're all be here yeah just my mom's
over there so they're not really safe
see that she has to be here in she's
already old then she has to be hitting
me hate it like hiding yeah because he
they find her I mean they're good
children you think it's me or my family
all my other sons are here in Los
Angeles my sisters are here and only my
mom and I gave my youngest daughter is
over there
so yeah I seen a lot of cheering on you
it's bad so your friends that are in the
same situation
yeah yeah why not mafia yeah fire once
you required once you do what they tell
you to do you already in it and it's
hard for you to get out because you
already know all what they do other
hangouts where they got the the other
drugs will have everything at first you
didn't affect me you should do in effect
me I had like I got like a three on it
yeah I had a you say a good feeling at
first but now it's affecting me mentally
it's affecting me but uh I'm going
through it I'm kind of scared to go bad
or because they're still fighting over
there they're still buying a lot of
ideas a lot of Chileans still I mean
it's not going to stop yes I'm on heroin
I hope you
I started when I was 13 years old I
stopped here and there I stopped like I
stopped when I go to prison here I went
to prison in Texas I went to prison they
had to isolate me isolate me because I
had the green light yeah see so
everybody knew on the green light it's
just forward together prisoners yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can hike so that's
why you got to put you solitary yourself
yeah and it's kind of scary I mean now
it's scary at first it was fun it was
fun killing me you sure was fun chilling
no I don't that's what people tell me
well I guess seven years for for one
life just let me do that I didn't know
in Texas that's when I gave my time
seven years in there and that's when
they put me in solitary
although no there was some invincible
magic no I just don't want to get time
for I was in Texas for seven years I did
kind of hiding
uh-huh really I should leave him a 10
have a sin that I bought but to steal
kind of scary
I put chains and locks in there I mean
because you got got shelving that
somebody's up there to get you and it's
uh it's of that feeling mr. bad food I
know be any worries very worried yes
yeah you need sour box and before I
could we were shopping people's heads up
the woman is a prostitute is a woman's
really like other prostitute in there
sometimes they give you some kind of
disease or everything so what we used to
do is we see a prostitute then used to
like point at you you take care that and
you already knew what to do they didn't
have to explain to you what to do or not
easy yeah and you infernal everybody you
don't matter because yeah the people and
parties are scared I secured the Mafia
yeah they won't they won't report you so
they just tell you point you out you
know get that one right there or the one
on the other corner and you know what
you do
so yeah they will used to do them
and after that like nothing happened
like maybe everything's cool let's just
keep doing what we're doing in but I got
tired of their life so I kind of wanted
to stay out of it but it's kind of
harder leaving the what cuz you can show
you I mean you're gonna be dead before
you before you leave them say you're
ready yeah you're already there you're
stuck in there you can you yeah so I
left and still hiding I'm right here Oh
lonely but I'm hiding yeah it's kind of
rough i shoplift in like earlier this
morning I went to the stores I wanted to
go steal some clothes that's what I do
for my you not really a seventy seventy
eight seventy eight seven
nine-thirty appreciably yeah yeah but
it's just like 72 hours and I mean yes I
tried to log you know Daisy
not now people with Spiro communion
we're gonna let ourselves draw you know
like
oh yeah yeah I got five four kids no
because there they could hear or
something you can check or nothing
because they'll find out for your
families and where you are I mean they
got a lot of connections you could
imagine yourself a lot of connections
yeah even here where every whatever
state yeah yeah but when when I listen
with them I was kind of young I looked
at different and I kind of like paint my
hair or live it with pretty hair no not
really I mean dude they will piss of my
face like the innocent of me against the
innocent of me that's how they could
tell I mean I had to read up take out my
tattoos from there my neg my face I had
tattoos and everything I took them off
the reason for cuz of that a lot of
Chileans over there can you do
you are any kind of it
yes I was I was stealing I liked it when
I was young but I was like 11 9 years
old I was still early
yeah I was already messed up messed up I
can't blame nobody but yeah I was
finding some kind of love him somewhere
else
and I found him and I got stuck here no
I just got my mom my mom she's leaving
she's got 84 he takes it yeah she's
hiding like that passed away got my
sister's here the reason why and that
means careful is because I don't want
them to get get them in trouble that I
love I love my kids and I wish I wish
you mom I wish I could go back home
sooner or later I'll go get it
and this juice
they give words thank you for everything
you guys doing and then people taking
care of my mom
and I think that to waking up or still
heavy dude
but can get her turn over I'm even
better with my daughter because of that
what I got into when I was young I mean
it's a it's a bad feeling it sure is a
bad feeling but at first it wasn't at
first he wasn't mean at birth and it was
good it was all good and everything you
know but now I mean you you feel steps
behind you you can't sleep I mean your
heads miss Stubbs yes I still worry
uh-huh I still worry yeah I still worry
about sometimes I don't even sleep like
I got like see my my can that put like
three locks and then inside I put two
one on the outside and I just have to
tell my neighbor open the outside and I
that's how that's how I got all cut it
out yeah
I was like 20 years with them just
kidding that's how you tell you just
kill it because we used to we used to
have other merchandise we say I'm
merchandise and we used to give it to
somebody and if you don't mean the the
money are you supposed to bring your
then they'll point you out you know take
your lap they'll just say that take care
that take care of that take care of that
maybe
it was it was kind of wrong especially
we worked really mentally he's a girl's
a prostitute
even though the homosexual there was a
lot of children from homosexuals - not
necessary person anyone anyone anyone
they pawn you - yeah anyone they point
you to leave yes they just tell you what
do take care of that oh yeah they're
real powerful I mean they were powerful
because they buy they buy the police
over here that that that bridge is there
something that bridges are I mean ours
that bridge is with ours I mean our
minds so a buddy a very like you
wouldn't come true because we used to
run the line used to run the line from
what is to Texas yeah and if we didn't
want you welcome over here sometimes
they were used to define they're used to
bring bodies from Texas to wires in the
trunks just to stash a movie on this
icon policy
the most horrible thing I've seen is
when they torture they tortured is this
lady they did it by cutting the eyes and
you had to see what if you're there
you've got to see what they're doing
yeah you got a watch you gotta watch
this yeah
little by little make you suffer take
one thing our and then another thing our
just to I guess to kill that thrill
that's really all we feel when we're
telling somebody slowly when you take
one eye out
oh let me take something else out here a
finger or you then your balls or I mean
just to make you suffer sometimes I
would do it I mean yeah they pawn you
out you have no choice you've got it do
it well you're gonna get yeah I mean I
haven't been over there for about a year
went on a year I haven't been over there
yeah I went back but I couldn't get too
close
I couldn't get too close I couldn't get
too close a reason why because you're
looking for me uh-huh I had a week
blonde week some some big glasses ahead
some woods I mean like like a cover
yes and you got disguises I disguise
myself I went up to Houston to Houston
yeah but I did stay there long because I
didn't want them to spot me or you know
yeah even in Houston wherever you know
you just have to I just when I'm coming
back
yeah it is kind of so bad it's a valium
in weather here in Texas what I gave my
seven years because I still had that
three on me so I went in go ahead and
kill this man
just for the fun of it no no just for
the fun of it for to to feel that three
are me I didn't run I did not eat it's
just I just felt good that good feeling
that I had and there was my last
cheering I did so now I'm wondering
whether I'm won it over there in Mexico
or El Paso anywhere they find me my life
is gone like I say it's better my life
when my family
yes the super now
you're very welcome
you